Générique
...
-Boualem Sansal, on parle beaucoup
de l'Afrique, mais en fait,
c'est une notion un peu générale
et on a tort de dire "l'Afrique",
parce qu'il n'y a pas une Afrique,
mais plusieurs.
Il y a l'Afrique du Nord,
de l'Ouest, de l'Est,
l'Afrique australe.
Elles ont toutes,
ces Afrique,
une vie et une histoire
différentes.
-Oui.
Sans jeu de mots, je voudrais
tirer une croix sur l'Afrique.
Le trait horizontal passerait
au niveau du Sahel,
donc de l'Atlantique
à la mer Noire.
Et puis, le vertical
qui partirait du Sahel
jusqu'à l'Afrique du Sud.
On a quatre régions
complètement différentes.
Le nord qui est blanc
et musulman,
et qui se rattache
à une histoire qui n'a rien
d'africaine,
plutôt méditerranéenne,
arabe et européenne.
Vous avez
une Afrique de l'Ouest
qui est très occidentale,
très occidentalisée.
-A cause de la colonisation ?
-A cause de la colonisation.
Et puis, la partie orientale
qui est complètement
à l'opposé de l'ouest,
la Corne de l'Afrique,
qui est plutôt sur l'Inde,
sur l'Asie,
qui est tournée vers l'Asie.
Et curieusement,
on a pensé
que c'était la volonté
des colonisateurs que les choses
se soient faites comme ça,
ces partages de territoires.
Une fois les indépendances acquises,
l'Afrique allait
vivre, voyager, échanger.
Pas du tout.
Tout s'est renforcé,
au contraire.
Les desseins,
dans les deux sens
du mot "dessein",
posés par les pays occidentaux
sont toujours là et renforcés.
La France défend ses positions
en Afrique de l'Ouest.
-C'est toujours un pré carré ?
On peut appeler ça le pré carré.
-Le pré carré pour chacun.
Alors, ça commence à bouger,
ces dernières années.
On sent par exemple
que le monde arabe veut
récupérer le Maghreb,
qui lui avait totalement échappé
après les colonisations.
-Vous dites que l'Afrique de l'Ouest
est très occidentalisée.
Mais en fait,
l'Afrique de l'Ouest a aussi
pour religion l'islam,
majoritairement, et cet islam
est venu d'une période
où il y a eu une espèce
de colonisation, justement...
Ce qu'on a appelé, d'ailleurs,
la colonisation orientale.
Enfin, ce sont les Arabes
qui ont colonisé d'abord
l'Afrique noire occidentale.
-Ecoutez,
c'est très différent.
L'islam est arrivé
en Afrique du Nord
et s'est superposé
à une religion.
C'est le christianisme
et le judaïsme.
Donc, il y avait déjà
une structure,
une base bien structurée
sur les métaphysiques
religieuses, etc.
Alors que dans l'Afrique
de l'Ouest,
il s'est plaqué
sur des religions
traditionnelles
et animistes, magiques.
Et donc...
Enfin, c'est des islams
très différents.
-Très différents.
Alors, il y a aussi
ce phénomène,
qui est absolument terrible,
qui s'appelle l'esclavage.
Et on parle beaucoup
de l'esclavagisme
qui a été entretenu
par les Européens,
avec ce commerce triangulaire.
Mais avant cet esclavagisme-là,
il y a eu aussi
ce qu'on a appelé
"l'esclavagisme oriental",
c'est-à-dire celui qui a été...
-Arabe.
-Et qui a été dénoncé, d'ailleurs,
par un grand écrivain
qui s'appelle Yambo Ouologuem...
-Bien sûr.
-...dans un livre qui s'appelle
"Le devoir de violence",
qui a fait beaucoup de bruit.
Yambo Ouologuem était un Malien.
Il a dénoncé cet esclavagisme
en disant : "Mais attendez,
"la pénétration islamiste
en Afrique de l'Ouest,
"elle est liée aux Arabes,
et en fait,
"l'esclavagisme européen n'est
qu'un épisode là-dedans."
-Oui, absolument.
-Ca lui a valu
beaucoup de critiques.
-Eh bien, écoutez,
l'islam est venu à cette idée
que si on ne se convertit pas
à l'islam,
on est mis en esclavage.
Voilà.
Donc, on est tué
ou mis en esclavage.
Donc, il a...
En arrivant en Afrique,
il a donc d'abord cherché
à islamiser les gens.
Ceux qui se sont convertis,
il n'y a pas de souci,
ils sont devenus musulmans
et sont entrés dans la machine
esclavagiste eux-mêmes.
Mais c'est vrai que l'esclavage
dans le monde arabe était énorme.
Je veux dire que c'est
dans un rapport de 1 à 100
entre ce que l'Occident
a déplacé de populations
et ce que le monde musulman
a déplacé.
-Vous voulez dire
qu'il y a eu
plus de déplacés
par le monde musulman
que par le monde occidental ?
-Beaucoup plus.
Plusieurs millions.
-D'accord.
-Ca a commencé très tôt
et ça continue.
Ce qu'on ne sait pas,
c'est que ça continue.
-Ca continue où ?
On parle beaucoup
de la Mauritanie.
-Pas seulement
la Mauritanie.
Venez en Algérie,
baladez-vous,
et vous verrez
tous ces migrants
qui viennent du sud,
du Sahel...
-Et qui sont rendus
à l'état d'esclavage ?
-C'est un esclavage moderne.
Je veux dire
qu'ils sont exploités
dans des conditions
absolument abominables.
Voilà, ils arrivent.
Ils partent
dans la clandestinité,
ils sont récupérés
par des négriers
qui les utilisent
dans des chantiers
plus ou moins officiels.
-Légaux.
Ils acceptent cela
car ils sont
dans une perspective
d'émigration vers le nord.
L'Algérie est juste un passage
pour se faire un peu d'argent.
-Une transition.
-Voilà, un transit.
Et puis, finalement,
ils sont piégés là-dedans
parce qu'ils sont vraiment
exploités.
Le gouvernement,
de temps en temps, réagit.
Parce que, évidemment,
les pays africains se plaignent
de ce qui se passe,
des mauvais traitements
que les pays du Maghreb infligent
à ces migrants.
-Et malheureusement, ça,
on n'en entend pas parler.
Dans les actualités
internationales,
ce n'est pas un fléau
dont on parle beaucoup.
-Le problème est occidental.
Les Occidentaux ont
de plus en plus peur
de parler de ce qui est en dehors
de leur pré carré.
-Parce qu'ils ont peur
d'être accusés
de racisme ?
-Absolument.
Ils ont peur de parler
de ce qui se passe
au Maroc, en Algérie,
en Tunisie.
-D'accord.
-Parce qu'on peut évidemment
leur opposer cela,
racisme, mensonge,
manipulation.
Comme il n'y a pas d'enquête,
on peut tout dire et le contraire.
Combien d'Africains ?
Dans le quartier où j'habite,
j'en vois des dizaines
et des dizaines tous les jours.
-Des Subsahariens.
Des Noirs africains.
-Voilà.
-Vous dites que les Occidentaux
n'en parlent pas
par peur d'être accusés
de racisme.
Les relations entre la France
et l'Algérie sont des relations
on ne peut plus compliquées,
évidemment.
Et ce passé, il ne passe pas.
-Ce passé...
Je vais vous dire
le fond de ma pensée.
Ce passé ne passera...
-Jamais ?
-Ne passera pas
tant que nos pays,
notamment l'Algérie,
ne seront pas
des Etats de droit
démocratiques.
Voilà.
Il faut que les Maghrébins puissent
s'exprimer librement
pour que la relation à l'autre
d'une manière générale
- les Français, les Allemands,
les Africains -
devienne
une relation normale.
Il faut du dialogue,
de la discussion.
On ne peut pas discuter.
Comment peut-on s'entendre ?
-Tant que l'Algérie sera gouvernée
par des autocrates,
ça ne pourra pas marcher ?
-On n'a pas le droit de parler,
donc on est tenu de tenir
le discours de la doxa,
le discours officiel.
Voilà.
Ou alors,
il faut être vraiment
l'opposant qui vit
à l'extérieur.
-Vous qui avez la dent très dure
avec le régime algérien,
avec le FLN
et avec les successeurs du FLN,
même si certains pères
de la révolution
sont encore là...
...comment vous avez réagi
quand, en 2005,
par exemple,
il y a eu un projet de loi
en France pour reconnaître
les bienfaits
de la colonisation ?
C'est un projet de loi
qui était inspiré
par la droite
qui était au pouvoir.
-Oui, je m'en souviens.
-Sous Jacques Chirac.
Evidemment, ça a créé
une polémique terrible.
Parce que les bienfaits
de la colonisation,
on sait que ça a des limites,
quand même.
Comment vous avez réagi à ça,
vous ?
-Ce qui est malheureux,
c'est le mot "bienfaits".
-Oui.
Le mot était maladroit ?
-Le mot est maladroit.
"Bienfaits" renvoie peut-être
à une notion quasi religieuse.
On a "bienfaits",
"bienfaiteur", etc.
Non, il y a
une réalité historique.
La France s'est installée
en Algérie.
Elle a fait...
Il faut faire un bilan.
Il y a l'actif et le passif.
Le passif, évidemment,
est très lourd.
La colonisation s'est faite
par des moyens essentiellement
militaires.
Par la suite,
elle s'est poursuivie
en utilisant
d'autres méthodes.
L'éducation...
-Oui, la colonisation
Jules Ferry, je dirais.
-Oui, voilà.
-On apporte la civilisation.
-Oui, un peu inspirées
par les saint-simoniens
et tout ça.
Voilà, il faut considérer
les colonisés
comme étant des partenaires,
etc.
-Tous les trois étaient
sur ce mode-là.
-Et sur ce plan-là, il y a eu
réellement un progrès énorme.
Je pourrais presque reprendre
l'expression de Macron
qui parlait
de "ruissellement".
-Oui, en parlant de la France,
pour le coup.
-La France a beaucoup investi.
Elle a investi pour elle,
évidemment.
C'était son nouveau territoire,
donc elle investissait chez elle,
pour le siens.
Mais par ruissellement,
les autochtones,
notamment les citadins,
en ont profité.
Moi, je fais partie
de ceux qui ont profité
de cela.
J'ai été à l'école,
j'ai été au lycée, je...
Mes parents étaient...
Ma mère était infirmière
au grand hôpital Mustapha
d'Alger.
Mon grand-père était
chef de gare.
-Tout ça, c'est grâce
à la colonisation ?
-C'est la conséquence.
Ce n'est pas "grâce".
C'est le ruissellement,
si vous voulez.
Les gens en ont profité.
En revanche,
ceux qui ont été perdus
dans ce mouvement,
ce sont les campagnards,
qui étaient isolés
dans leur campagne.
La civilisation n'est pas encore
arrivée jusque-là.
-On leur a peut-être pris
leurs terres aussi, non ?
-Aussi, oui.
Il y a eu des spoliations
énormes, bien sûr.
Ils ont été abandonnés.
Ils sont sortis de l'histoire,
bloqués, comme ça,
dans un espace-temps...
Et ils ont été
les premiers à rejoindre
les mouvements
révolutionnaires.
-Ce qui est venu surtout
des zones rurales.
-Les citadins ont rejoint
bien plus tard.
-Donc, ce passé passe mal.
Et d'ailleurs, les présidents,
quand ils vont en Algérie,
en visite officielle
ou en visite d'Etat,
ce n'est jamais simple,
c'est toujours compliqué.
On l'a vu encore récemment
avec Emmanuel Macron,
qui a eu du mal
à fixer son agenda
parce que le pouvoir voyait
d'un mauvais oeil
ce qu'il pouvait faire
ici ou là.
On va regarder des extraits,
vous allez voir,
de tout ça.
*-La liesse dépasse parfois
les services d'ordre.
Jacques Chirac est ici
le président
d'une France enviée
pour son niveau économique
et où de nombreux Algériens
voudraient vivre,
même s'ils aiment
d'abord leur pays.
*-Nous avons un passé commun.
Il est complexe, douloureux,
et il a pu parfois
comme empêcher
de regarder l'avenir.
-Alors, voilà.
Jacques Chirac,
c'était en 2003.
On lui demande des visas.
-Pareil avec Macron.
-C'est la même chose.
On lui a demandé des visas aussi.
-Il y a eu le Hirak,
pourtant.
Il y a eu ce mouvement
qui est né en 2019,
populaire,
plutôt bon enfant,
d'ailleurs,
pour se révolter
contre le régime.
Il y a une espèce de dégagisme
qui était réclamé.
Et puis, il y a eu
la crise sanitaire
et tout cela a été enterré,
ça n'a jamais marché.
Le régime est toujours là.
Je dirais : l'Etat profond algérien
est toujours là.
-La France officielle
n'a jamais traité
qu'avec le pouvoir.
C'est un pouvoir de fait.
Il est là.
-Tiens, on voit
une photo de l'Hirak.
-Oui, voilà.
-C'est des démonstrations
de rue
qui avaient lieu
tous les vendredis.
-Oui, tous les vendredis.
La France officielle a fait
le choix de traiter
avec l'Algérie officielle,
le pouvoir de fait.
C'est une dictature
militaro-policière qui,
comme l'a dit Macron,
vit sur la rente historique.
-Oui.
-"Nous sommes les libérateurs.
Le pays nous appartient.
"C'est avec nous
qu'il faut discuter.
"Nous représentons le peuple."
-Pour vous,
la France a eu tort
de continuer à parler
avec le régime
alors que la population
se révoltait ?
-Absolument.
-Qu'est-ce
qu'elle aurait dû faire ?
-C'est à eux
d'inventer la voie.
Les problèmes, évidemment,
sont très complexes.
Voilà, il faut chercher,
essayer de travailler
avec le pouvoir, bien sûr.
C'est un pouvoir de fait.
C'est avec lui qu'on traite
les grandes questions.
-Mais c'est un pouvoir légal,
quand même.
-Pas du tout.
Ni légal, ni légitime.
-D'accord.
-Il est arrivé au pouvoir
par des coups d'Etat
et il ne se maintient
que par une répression
quotidienne féroce.
De plus en plus,
en ce moment.
-Et donc, Macron a eu tort
d'aller là-bas ?
-Moi, je pense que oui.
Non, je ne dirais pas
qu'il a tort.
Il a été mal conseillé
et mal préparé.
Voilà.
Il faut du temps,
il faut préparer le terrain
à différents niveaux.
Il aurait dû tenter
de rencontrer
la société civile,
ce qu'il n'a pas fait.
-Donc, vous remettez
un peu en question
les conclusions
de la commission Stora.
C'est une commission
qui a été installée
à la demande
d'Emmanuel Macron
par Benjamin Stora,
qui est un grand historien,
qui est lui-même natif d'Algérie.
C'est un Juif d'Algérie.
Il a créé cette commission
et cette commission est chargée
de trouver les moyens
d'apaiser les relations
entre la France
et l'Algérie.
L'ouverture des archives,
autant de choses comme ça.
Ses conclusions, vous estimez
qu'elles sont bonnes ou pas ?
-Ce n'est pas ça
qui a été convenu.
-Oui.
-Macron a été roulé
dans la farine.
-Ah oui ?
-Il était question,
au départ,
que les deux gouvernements désignent
chacun leur commission.
Donc, commission française
présidée
par Benjamin Stora,
qui s'est mis au travail
et qui,
un mois ou deux après,
a rendu son rapport.
Il vaut ce qu'il vaut.
-Il n'y a pas eu l'équivalent
en Algérie.
-En Algérie,
le président a désigné,
mais pas officiellement,
un certain M. Chikhi,
qui est directeur
des Archives nationales
et conseiller du président
en matière d'histoire
et d'archives.
-Oui.
-Il n'a réuni
aucune commission
et n'a pas produit
une demi-ligne.
Normalement, en France,
ils auraient dû arrêter.
Ils n'auraient pas dû
commencer le travail
avant que
la partie algérienne
ne commence elle-même
le sien.
C'est un travail à deux.
Il ne s'est fait
que d'un côté.
-C'est unilatéral,
cette affaire.
-Unilatéral.
Et du coup,
ce n'est pas contradictoire,
donc on ne peut rien dire
du rapport
de Benjamin Stora.
Il faudrait
le comparer à quoi ?
Si on avait un rapport Chikhi,
on dirait :
"Voilà où les points de vue
se rapprochent
"et voilà
où ils s'écartent."
Et on aurait fait peut-être
une troisième commission
pour, précisément,
ces points de divergence.
Ca ne s'est pas fait.
Il n'y a pas eu
une seule déclaration,
pas une réunion
de la partie algérienne.
Voilà.
La partie française
a été roulée
dans la farine.
Macron se retrouve
avec un rapport.
Que faire ?
S'il ne fait rien,
il va déplaire à Alger.
"Alors, voilà,
"Benjamin Stora propose
ceci et cela.
"Vous ne faites rien."
-Donc, la politique
et le discours
des Algériens,
c'est toujours plus loin
dans la repentance.
-C'est la manipulation.
C'est...
Vous savez,
le pouvoir algérien
est issu
d'une révolution.
Il fonctionne encore
sur le paradigme
de la révolution.
Moi, c'est à la mort
de Boumédiène
que j'ai appris
que M. Boumédiène
ne s'appelait pas
Boumédiène.
C'est un nom de guerre.
Que le patron
des services secrets,
M. Kasdi Merbah,
ce n'était pas son vrai nom.
C'est un nom de guerre.
-Donc, tout est
dans le camouflage.
-C'est la culture
de la révolution.
Ils se sont battus
dans la clandestinité.
C'est une armée
très puissante,
des services secrets
très puissants.
-D'accord.
-Et c'est resté.
Et c'était tellement...
C'était tellement
bénéfique...
Je vais reprendre
le mot "bienfaits".
C'était tellement bénéfique
pour le pouvoir
qu'il a gardé la chose.
On ne sait pas
qui décide en Algérie.
qui se réunit avec qui,
qui représente quoi
et pourquoi.
Et ils jouent aux dominos
à longueur de journée.
-Je voudrais
qu'on revienne sur...
Bon, il y a l'Algérie
et l'Algérie en Afrique.
Souvent,
l'Afrique n'a pas
très bonne presse
de par le monde
pour des raisons multiples
et variées.
Pourtant,
elle a des atouts.
Elle a une richesse de sous-sol,
elle a une population jeune.
Néanmoins, elle souffre
de multiples maux ici ou là.
La famine,
le réchauffement climatique.
Et puis, il y a
un de vos chevaux
de bataille,
c'est l'islamisme.
En 1999,
vous sortez un livre,
"Le serment des barbares",
qui va faire du bruit.
D'une certaine façon,
vous alertez un peu l'Occident,
avec ce livre, sur les ravages
que ça peut faire.
-Oui, absolument.
Oui, oui.
C'était pourtant
très visible.
Et l'islam est une entité
qui a sa propre vie.
L'islam est un processus
historique qui avance.
Avec ou sans nous,
il avance.
Le monde musulman a vécu
le démantèlement
de l'Empire ottoman
comme l'humiliation suprême.
L'islam était
en train de mourir.
Il perdait ce qui était
son essence même :
le calife,
c'est-à-dire le représentant de Dieu
et du prophète sur Terre.
Les Occidentaux ont fait
une erreur colossale,
c'est d'enlever le calife.
Il fallait le garder.
Même attaché à sa chaise,
il fallait le garder,
comme un symbole.
Et à cette époque
est né...
Cette humiliation a créé
un mot qui a fait florès
dans l'ensemble
du monde musulman.
C'est le mot "nahda",
qui veut dire "renaissance".
Il faut absolument
se battre
pour remettre l'islam
sur ses rails.
Donc,
un problème religieux.
Et les religieux
se sont mis
à travailler.
Comment remettre l'islam
dans sa...
-Une espèce de revanche.
-Après coup, prophétique,
donc en reprenant le chemin
qui est le sien.
-De l'islam,
on est passé à l'islamisme.
-C'est la même chose.
L'islamisme est un mot
inventé encore en France
pour ne pas froisser
les musulmans.
C'est un mot qui n'existe pas
dans le monde musulman.
Je n'ai jamais entendu
le mot "islamisme" en Algérie.
On parle de bons musulmans
et de mauvais musulmans.
-Et vous,
vous dénoncez tout cela.
Vous avez une oeuvre
qui est extrêmement riche,
très intéressante, passionnante.
Et vous continuez
à vivre en Algérie.
-Oui.
-Vous n'avez pas peur
pour vous ?
-Euh...
Ecoutez, j'ai eu peur
au temps des GIA.
-Donc, pendant la guerre civile
algérienne.
On va dire
entre 1990 et 2000.
-Le FIS...
D'abord, il y a
la période du FIS,
c'est-à-dire...
On va dire 85, par là,
jusque 92, 93, par là.
Les islamistes ont cherché
à s'attirer
les bonnes grâces
des élites.
Ils se sont dit :
"On a besoin de ces gens-là."
Nous étions pour eux
des coopérants techniques.
Et puis, le FIS est passé.
Arrivent les GIA.
Les GIA, c'est simple,
c'est très brutal :
"Qui n'est pas avec nous
est contre nous." Voilà.
Si vous manifestez
et que vous êtes
contre eux,
vous devenez un ennemi.
Voilà,
c'est comme ça que...
Là, j'ai eu peur
parce qu'ils ont créé
une section spéciale
qui s'appelait le FIDA,
Front islamique
de je ne sais pas quoi,
chargé spécifiquement
d'assassiner
les journalistes
et les intellectuels.
Et ils en ont tué pas mal.
-Et maintenant ?
-Et puis,
changement de...
Ensuite, les GIA ont été...
-Oui, dissous.
-Voilà, ratiboisés.
C'était fini.
Les islamistes,
maintenant, sont
sur la même
longueur d'onde
que les islamistes
en France.
C'est-à-dire l'agit-prop
dans les banlieues,
on s'installe,
on travaille
avec les autorités.
-C'est de l'entrisme.
Tout le reste est caché.
-Je voudrais quand même dire...
Parce que vous êtes
assez sombre dans le constat
que vous faites,
mais vous êtes aussi assez optimiste
pour l'avenir.
Vous gardez,
en tout cas, espoir.
Parce que vous avez écrit,
en 2021,
un livre qui s'appelle
"Lettres d'amitié,
de respect
"et de mise en garde
"aux peuples et aux nations
de la terre."
C'est un manifeste
qui est assez intéressant
car vous dites :
"Unissons-nous
et ça ira beaucoup mieux."
Vous êtes quand même un...
Vous gardez espoir, quoi.
-D'abord, ce livre fait suite
à un autre livre :
"Poste restante : Alger -
"Lettre de colère et d'espoir
à mes compatriotes."
-Il y a 10 ans, alors.
-Oui.
Je m'adresse à mes compatriotes
en disant :
"On passe notre temps à se plaindre,
mais agissons."
Si on ne fait rien,
on n'a pas le droit
de se plaindre.
Ca veut dire qu'on accepte
et il vaut mieux
accepter pour de bon,
peut-être même
rallier le pouvoir.
Mais si on se plaint,
se battre est un devoir.
-D'accord.
-Si on ne se bat pas,
on se la ferme.
-D'accord.
-Et...
J'avais titré cette lettre
"Poste restante".
Je savais qu'elle n'arriverait pas
à ses destinataires.
Ce livre a été interdit.
Puis, je me suis dit :
"Il y a une évolution
dans le monde.
"Il n'y a plus
de problèmes particuliers,
"il n'y a plus
que des problèmes généraux."
Mon problème, c'est le vôtre.
Le vôtre, c'est le mien.
On ne peut pas y échapper.
Donc, il faut traiter ça...
-A l'échelle universelle.
-Voilà.
-Et vous êtes universaliste.
-Je le suis.
Donc, je m'adresse
un peu à ceux qui,
officiellement,
représentent l'universalisme :
c'est l'ONU.
Mais l'ONU, c'est un...
Ce machin est vraiment...
-Ca ne sert à rien ?
-Ca ne sert à rien.
-Je voudrais que vous répondiez
à un petit questionnaire.
Quelle est votre musique préférée
en Afrique ?
-Là, j'ai découvert...
Comme je suis un fan
de Kateb Yacine,
eh bien, je suis un fan
de son fils,
Amazigh Kateb,
qui est un chanteur.
Et il chante le gnawa.
Musique gnawa
-On entend
un peu de gnawa, oui.
Le gnawa,
c'est une musique...
Il y a un festival tous les ans
à Essaouira, je crois.
-Oui.
C'est à la fois religieux,
politique...
C'est un truc
très compliqué.
Il y a du religieux.
-Un peu de vaudou aussi.
-Oui, oui, absolument,
absolument.
Et là,
dans ce mouvement gnawa,
il est en train d'innover.
Il a introduit
une instrumentation
moderne.
-Oui.
-Mais il met un...
Il ne fait pas
que de la politique.
Il fait un peu de l'incitation
à la révolte.
-D'accord.
-C'est un peu...
En fait, je pense que bientôt,
il va remplacer
ce que le raï a été
il y a 20 ans.
-Qui est une musique
aussi revendicative.
-De revendication
dans bien des domaines.
-Et donc,
le gnawa a
cette particularité aussi.
-Il a cette particularité.
-Quelle est la ville en Afrique
que vous préférez ?
-Euh...
Marrakech, mais pas
pour son côté comme ça...
-Bling-bling ?
-Voilà, pas du tout.
C'est qu'on ne s'intéresse pas
assez à cette région
qui est absolument
d'une richesse historique
considérable.
-Au pied de l'Atlas, alors.
-Oui, au pied de l'Atlas.
C'est là que sont nées
les deux dynasties islamiques
les plus... qui nous inspirent
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
qui ont inspiré...
C'est Daech, voilà.
C'est à Marrakech
qu'est née
la dynastie almohade.
-Oui.
-C'est Daech puissance 10.
Cet empire s'est constitué.
Il a gouverné
tout le Maghreb
et toute l'Espagne.
-Mais vous qui,
vis-à-vis de l'islam,
avez beaucoup
de prévention...
-Il faut étudier
ces choses-là.
-Ah, d'accord.
-Parce que là,
on a vu ce que...
L'islam en tant que religion,
je dirais qu'il est...
Je ne dirais pas
qu'il est inoffensif, mais bon...
La politique
en tant que politique,
on ne peut pas dire
qu'elle est inoffensive.
Mais mettez-les ensemble
et c'est du plutonium 81.
-Plutonium, d'accord.
-Avec ça,
on fait des bombes.
C'est ce qui s'est passé.
-Un écrivain ?
-J'ai découvert...
A cette époque, je venais
de sortir mon premier livre
et j'ai fait plusieurs tournées
avec lui.
J'ai découvert
un homme extraordinaire.
C'est Ahmadou Kourouma.
-Ahmadou Kourouma.
"Allah n'est pas obligé".
-Voilà.
Il m'a appris qu'il avait été
réfugié politique en Algérie
et qu'il connaissait bien l'Algérie.
-Alors que lui était
d'origine guinéenne
et né en Côte-d'Ivoire.
-Voilà.
-C'est un très grand écrivain
aujourd'hui décédé.
-Un très grand écrivain.
Il avait une connaissance
de l'Afrique prodigieuse.
Et dans...
C'est très fin, quoi.
C'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas
assez profité de lui.
-Merci, Boualem Sansal.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA